hey guys this is andrew from
trendingcensus.com so for those who
don't know yet i've been working as a
professional trailer on the option
market for the past six years in hong
kong
and i've decided guys to make a youtube
channel a few months ago
because i want to pass the knowledge
guys i want to show you all the
different tools and techniques that pro
traders actually using to make money on
the markets
and most importantly guys i want to show
you how to use it yourself
so if you want to know about all the
stuff you guys are in the right place
so today i want to make an update on
fubu tv let's get into it
[Music]
so this is fubu tv charts let's go on
the daily time frame first guys
and let's see what we have so i did my
last video guys on the 10th of
march so 10th of march was here
and i was saying guys patience is key
don't rush
into this stock because 27
is uh of course uh supports that
hold here but uh it's not a strong
support guys and
when you know we had this correction
here
i could kind of see that the correction
was not finished you know
we were missing something this was too
sharp guys this move down was too sharp
for the correction to be actually done
you know usually moves like this
it's like abc's so you can apply this to
a lot of stuff but you usually need to
find
three waves so this is an abc so now
to me the situation is different we
broke 27 that was a short-term support
you can see here we have consolidation
here we have consolidation
here we have a reaction and here we
broke it and we're losing to 20 percent
so 27 is a support was a support it is
now a resistance
now we having this abc so i was telling
you guys that 23
was my support level it's actually you
know a bit
not perfect the way i find my support
level is just that i check in the past
where i have the most reactions all
right and i have
here a reaction at 23 so that's why i
said 23
but if i look i have here erection at
21.75
and here at 20 and this one is at 21.75
as well
so let's call it 21.5 yes all right this
support level is a long-term support so
it's not very precise
it can be you know a bit messy but look
guys what we're having here on the daily
time frames of daily and four hours time
frame are the most important ones
uh we have the 200 period moving average
which is the
most important one as well that is
coming at this level guys so we have a
double signal
so that's why here i'm turning
definitely bullish
you know uh so we have some damage here
that needs to be repaired all right this
is going to take some time
so don't expect us i mean you can expect
a strong move up but 27 is going to act
as
a resistance so you can expect yes
something like this now to happen all
right so we go to 27
we get rejected maybe not go back to uh
220 maybe we come back to 20 and then we
go again we break it
we retest it and then we have this this
resistance
so here i connect the two recent highs
in this move down
this is what you guys looking for this
is what you want to happen
this is going to be the signal that
things are doing better that the flows
are starting to be bullish again
the macd look at the macd guys it's
strongly negative you need the macd to
turn
green you know the signal that is here
the the red bars
need to become green again and we're
going to have some bullish momentum this
is going to happen
when we actually going to break this
downward sloping trend line
this is a nearly signal guys that i'm
giving you right now
this is what you're looking for all
right everything that is happening here
is you don't care it can be messy guys
it can go
very like a different ways but 21
is support if you break it guys things
change all right
we need to reconsider everything i'm
convinced it's going to hold
and you can have this kind of scenario
you can also have something like this
you know more messy
but ultimately guys we're going to break
here and then re-test
and once we do once we test it i don't
know if it's going to be here
or here i don't know if it's going to be
end of april
if or if it's going to be mid-may but
you know mid-may is kind of a maximum
and then we're going to have the
strong move up that is coming back all
right guys so this is what you're
looking for
you're gonna have here a period of
consolidation again
once again guys when you have strong
moves down like this it takes some time
before the bullish momentum comes back
so it's gonna be messy
21 20 22 is a beautiful level to buy
uh below 19 careful guys careful it
means that
all i'm saying has actually not been
enough to sustain this market
uh that is for some reason bearish uh
this is not the case right now but if
you break
20 it's gonna be the case so this is
kind of your safety line guys
so let's see what happens let's find out
if uh
my analysis would actually be good or
not it was
uh three weeks ago let's see if it is in
one or two weeks
so that's it for me guys i hope you
enjoyed this video and if you did
please don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button
so you're gonna be the first to know
when i plan anything new
and stay close to show i see you guys